[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم القصه التي نحن بصددها الليله
ليست كباقي القصص التي تمر علينا بشكل عام
او في المقابله على وجه التحديث نحن
الليله ايها الساده في حضره الحزن
والماساه والالم من جهه والبطوله
والاستثنائيه والعظمه من جهه اخرى وتحديدا
في حضره العداء العالمي السير مو فرح او
حسين عبدي الشاب البريطاني الصومالي الذي
تعكس قصته واحده من ابشع اوجه الاستغلال
الحضاري والعبوديه وكيف نكون منصفين ايضا
تعكس ماذا يعني ان تبقى في بلادك المحطمه
والمهشمه في العالم الثالث والتي يفترسها
الفقر والحرب والجهل في مقابل ان تتاح لك
فرصه الهجره والانتقال الى بلد اوروبيه
ولد بطلنا محمد فرح في الثالث اذار عام
1983 في مدينه قابيلي في اراضي الصومال
التي تعرف اليوم باسم صومالي لاند الدوله
التي اعلنت استقلالها طرف واحد عن الدوله
الام والصومال كانت البلاد تعيش انا ذاك
اجواء اضطراب الحرب الاهليه ما ادى الى
مقتل والده وعمره اربع سنوات فقط ليرسل مو
فرح مع توامه حسن للعيش مع عمه في جيبوتي
حيث اقامه هناك حتى جاءت امراه صوماليه لا
يعرفها وقامت باخذه الى بريطانيا تحت اسم
ملفق هو مو فرح لتفصيله عن عائلته وعن
توامه حسن الذي بقي في جيبوتي يملكهم وفرح
قصتين قصه كان يقدمها للاعلام قبل ان يكشف
عن اسمه الحقيقي وقصه اخرى هي القصه
الحقيقيه التي كشف عنها في عام 2022 للعام
الحالي وهي انه كان مختطفا من قبل سيده
صوماليه فصلته عن عائلته في جيبوتي
والصومال واجبرته ان يعيش في منزلها
ويخدمها قبل ان يحكي لمدربه في المدرسه عن
الحقيقه ليقوم المدرب بالاشراف على الى
عائله صوماليه اخرى هذا الجانب الماساوي
في حياه الشعب لكن الذهب لمع لاحقا واصبح
واحدا من ابرز نجوم البلاد كعداء
الاستثنائي نال ما نعلم من البطولات
والجوائز وكي لا نطيل عليكم اترككم مع بطل
هذه الحكايه مو فرح فاهلا ومرحبا بكم
[موسيقى]
مو اهلا وسهلا بك نبدا حلقتنا بالخارج
منزلك ما قصه هذا
ذكرني بلندن يعني ما هي قصته
يعني غريبه ان يكون في منزل صحيح
الى المملكه المتحده انت لا تنسى الذكريات
ابدا واي لحظات في حياتك عندما ذهبت الى
لندن رايت ان صندوق الهاتف الاحمر كان
مميزه وبصراحه عندما فتحت الفرصه يتمكن من
القيام بذلك في منزل كنت مثل يا الهي هذا
مثل لندن
هل تحمل يعني ذكريات مزدوجه بين لين
الصومال
في ذهنك
المتحده لانني عندما وصلت كنت طفله صغيره
جدا في التاسعه من عمري لبدء حياه جديده
هنا لكن لدي ذكريات متواضعه في الصومال
خصوصا عندما كنت طفلا صغيرا العب كره
القدم في الخارج الى اين ينظر العداء وهو
يجري اثناء الجري ينظر الى اقدام زميله
السباق تبدا بالتفكير والتساؤل كم بقيه
للفوز لسباق جري مسافه خمسه كيلومترات
تبقى لديك 400 متر وعليك ان تنقب عما تبقى
لديك من طاقه وان تكون على درايه بموقعك
وانك على المسار الصحيح لانه هناك ثمانيه
ممرات الممر الخارجي يعني الجري لمسافه
اكبر عليك استهداف الممر الاول او اقرب
ممر للداخل لانه يمنح افضليه عند
المنعطفات وكل ما شعرت بالراحه زادت قدرتك
على المضي قدما هل تشعر بنبض العداء الاخر
بقلبه بضربات قلبه العداء الزميل المنافس
لك هل تشعر به
ههه
عندما نكون على المسار فاناهم ينادونك
وعندما تقوم بالاحمار فانه ينادون عليك
للتحقق من رقمك بعد ذلك تذهب الى غرفه
بارده
بالوصول الى هذه المرحله وكان لدي ايمان
عميق لانني استحق ذلك فقد حققته ذلك
الانجاز لكن مره اخرى استغرق الامر مني
سنوات عده لبناء هذا الايمان لتحقيق هذا
الانجاس كاس العالم
سابدا معك سباق انا فقط 10 متر انا بطل
ايضا يعني سباقات الجري 10 امتار سنبدا
معك هذا السباق
يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
تقول انه كانت الرياضه هي المخرج بالنسبه
لي كنت اركض اجري حتى اتخلص من همومي بما
ان انا يعني ممارس هذه الرياضه البسيطه
حدثني كيف كانت الرياضه في حياتك كيف كانت
مخرج همم من تلك الاوضاع الصعبه التي كنت
تعيش
طقس
الرياضه جزء كبير من حياتي لولا الرياضه
والاشياء العظيمه التي حققتها لما كنت
اتحدث معكم اليوم الرياضه ساعدتني على
الهروب
وكما تعلمون شكرا لمدرس تربيه البدنيه في
المدرسه الذي اكتشف موهبتي ولاحظ الاهمال
الذي كنت اعاني منه وساعدني ووقف الى
جانبه
وهو يجري بقوه بدون توقف بسرعه كبيره جدا
اريد ان افهم هذا الشعور تحديدا وانت تجري
بكثافه وبسرعه وبقوه وبدون توقف
نعم
على اكثر مما تعتقد انك تمتلكه بصراحه
هناك اوقات تعلم فيها انك تكافح لكن عقليا
عليك ان تحفر بعمق لتحصل على المزيد رؤيه
المنافسين والاشخاص الذين يتحدونني في
سباق تمنحني الدافع بالنسبه لاكثر اللحظات
التي تبعث على الفخر في مسيره المهنيه رغم
الاوقات الصعبه والتدريب تحت المطر وفي
اسوا الظروف ان تتوج بالفوز بمداليه ذهبيه
واسمع النشيد الوطني
في الميدان
ما هي السوره التي تظهر لك امامك هل تهرب
من شيء ام تذهب باتجاه شيء باتجاه الذهبي
البطوله والنجاح
وساقوم بتنفيذها عندما تبدا بالتدريب
لممارسه الجري فانك تقوم بذلك بشكل يومي
لكن عندما تتدرب فانك تفكر بشكل مختلف عن
ما ستفعل اليوم وماذا عن عائلته واطفالي
هناك الكثير من الافكار تدور في ذهنك ولكن
عندما تسابق واكون في الميدان فانا دائم
التفكير في كيفيه الفوز وكيف احقق ذلك في
اغلب الاحيان كل ما انفذه في المضمار يتم
القيام به اثناء التدريب لذا فان تحضيره
لتكون قادرا على الجري بهذه السرعه يجعل
الناس تتسائل بذهول كيف انني قمت بذلك لقد
فعلت كل شيء في التدريب وتطلب الامر
اسابيع واشهرا من التدريب والعمل الجاد
وقطعت الكثير من الاميال لكن يجب ان يكون
لديك هذا التفكير وان تؤمن بشيء وتس بسيطه
وغالبا عندما يتعلق الامر بالممرات
النهائيه وانت تسمع الصافره فانك تضع نفسك
في الموضع الصحيح وتركز وتطبق ما تدربت
عليها وهكذا تشعر انك وصلت الى النهايه
عندما تعبر ذلك الخط هذا ما يحفزني كل يوم
اكثر فاكثر اول ذهبيه حصلت عليها ما هو
الشعور الذي يعني اضاءه في ذهنك اول ذهبيه
ثم فاسكو
عندما كنت صغيرا وهي الميداليه الاوروبيه
للناشئين كانت مميزه بالنسبه لي كنت تحت
ال 20 عاما وكانت تلك هي اللحظه التي
انطلقت فيها فزت اصبحت الافضل في اوروبا
وفي هذه اللحظه بعد تجربه طعم الفوز اصبح
من الواجب علي تغيير اسلوب تدريبه وتطوير
اداءه لانتقل من فئه المبتدئين الى فئه
البالغين كان ذلك صعبا في ذلك سن لا يكون
لديك الادراك الكافي وبذلك تستمر الحياه
ثم تصبح الجامعه ويصبح لديك الكثير من
الامور التي يمكن ان تصرف انتباها عانيت
قليلا في الانتقال الى فئه البالغين لكن
بعدها بدات بشكل تدريجي استوعب طريقه
التدريب والتفكير بشكل افضل في مستوى
قدراته والتامل في مهارات اللاعبين الافضل
مني وبعد ذلك بدات في تعلم المزيد عن
كيفيه التدريب الاستعداد ثم الفوز اول
ميداليه ذهبيه لك طالب في فئه البالغين
نلتها عام 2006 كانت على مستوى اوروبا كان
ذلك اول تتويجا رئيسي حيث فزت على مستوى
المقاطعه وبعد ذلك وصلت السعي نحو
الفوزان 2016
في شعرته فيها بالفخر لان الالعاب
الاولمبيه في وطنك حيث نشات وترى الامه
تقف خلفك وتشجعك كل ما نظرت الى الوراء
اشعر بالقشعريره لانه ليس هناك الكثير من
الرياضيين الذين حققوا ما قمت به ثانيا ان
احقق ذلك الفوز بوجود الناس لدعم والكثير
من الاشخاص الذين يقودونني الى الفوز اذ
كانت صورتي على الملصقات وكان الجميع
يتحدث عن مهارتي وهل يمكنني ان انجح في
ذلك ام لا لو لم يحدث ذلك
بعد بعد الفوز في اولمبياد لندن في
الذهبيه في 5000 متر و10 الاف متر وظهرت
النتيجه
ما هي الرساله الاولى التي فكرتها ان ان
ان ان ان تصلها ولمن تحديدا للشعب
الصومالي لاسرتك لمن افتقدتهم للشعب
البريطاني لمن تحديدا تحمل الرساله الاولى
الى حقيقه الجميع يسعى للمشاركه في
الالعاب الاولمبيه ومن ثم الفوز
بالميداليه الذهبيه الاولمبيه في وطنك كان
الامر رائعا ولم يكن هذا الانجاز لاجل فقط
وانما لجميع الاشخاص الموجودين في العالم
حتى يشاهد كيف انني تجاوزت ما مررت به من
عقبات في حياته اعتقد انها كانت اكثر
اللحظات التي شعرت فيها بالفخر
في الالعاب الاولمبيه شاركتنا عائلتها هذا
الفوز حيث كانت زوجته في الميدان وكانت
على وشكي ولاده ابنتي التوام وكانت ابنتي
كانت ذلك المشهد مليئا بالعواطف فلولا
وجوده هؤلاء الاشخاص في حياته لما تمكنت
من تحقيق هذا الانجاز اجل لا اصدق انه مر
على ذلك الفوز اكثر من 10 سنوات حتى الان
طيب انا في طريق الفوز عليك اليوم سافوز
عليك في هذه اللعبه كيف كان طعم الخساره
انت تحدثت عن طعم الفوز طعم الخساره هل
جربته هل تشعر بمراره حينما تخسر او تحقق
مثلا الميداليه الفضيه وليس الذهبيه
هذا حتى عندما العب مع اطفال لا احب ان
اخسر هذا مجرد جزء مني لقد تعلمته ان طعم
الخساره ماريرا لكن في مرحله ما يجب ان
توقنا بان كل ما سيرتفع سيكون مصيره
الهبوط وانه في احيانا ستخسر وستتحقق
الفوز في احيانا اخرى هذه هي الطريقه التي
ستساعدك على النهوض بنفسك عندما تخسر تشعر
بمراره لكنني احمد الله وفي كثير من
الاحيان اراجع نفسي لاعرف كيف حدث ذلك وما
الذي احتاج الى تغييره عليك ان تكون صادقا
مع نفسك
لا يمكنك تغيير الخساره لكن يمكنك فهمه ما
حدث من اخطاء لتتجنبها مستقبلا الخساره
جزء من اللعبه واعتقد ان اصعب شيء هو
عندما تخسر المسابقه بسبب جزء من الثانيه
طيب
بسبب جزء جزء من الثانيه انت الان على
بوابه الاربعين متى ينتهي العمر الرياضي
للعداد الرياضيين عمر الانجاز والبطولات
والنجاحات
مهنه استثنائيه ولكن مره اخرى الامر يتعلق
بالجسد في بعض الاحيان انه ليس فقط ما تود
القيام به لكنه ايضا كيف يستجيب الجسد
لذلك ماذا يقول الجسد
بوليسي
على استعداد تقريبا للتوقف الان لكن لا
يزال لدي الرغبه في الجري عندما اتوقف اود
ان اكون قادرا على الانخراط في المجتمع من
جديد مع جيل الشباب واجراء التغييرات التي
نحتاجها في الرياضه لو لم يكن لدي نموذج
يحتذى به لما كنت قادرا على ان احقق ما
حققته ومره اخرى كان ذلك بفضل حصول على
دعم من نظام الرعايه الاجتماعيه ومعلم
التربيه البدنيه الذي امن بمهاراته في
المستقبل سوف افكر دائما بما سافعله بعد
ان حققت كل هذه الانجازات وكيف يمكنني
مساعدته مجتمع على تغيير جيل الشباب
وطريقه تفكيرهم بالنسبه للاطفال سنا يتعلق
الامر كله بالتجارب التي سيمر بها هل
لديها في اسره موفراح عداء صغير رياضي
صغير
حاليا
ماشاء الله وهناك عائله اخرى لدي اربعه
اطفال جميلين وانا احاول ان ادعمهم ذهنيا
وجسديا اطفال ناشطون لكن يجب ان يمنح
الفرس وانواصل دعمهم في ذلك بالنسبه
لاحاول ان اطبق ما فعله مدرس تربيه
البدنيه الخاصه وكيف قدم لي الدعم حين
اخذني الى نادي المحلي احدى اطفال التوام
تتنافس على مستوى المقاطعه في مسابقه
الجري لانها تحب هذه الرياضه بينما يحب
ابنه اللعيبه كره القدم وانا ادعمه كواليد
في تقديم كل ما يمكنني فعله
لدينا قصتين مش قصه واحده قصتين ههه
سنه وقصه قديمه عاشت مكتومه داخل الموفره
وقبل ذلك من المشوار هزيمتك في هذه
المباراه حتى نعد الحوار
[موسيقى]
ههه
على وقت تزايدي معدلات الفقر وانعدام
الامن والاستقرار نتيجه الحروب الاهليه
والفساد وسوء الاداره المستشري في العديد
من دول العالم الثالث لا يجد الكثير من
مواطن هذه البلدان سوى ركوب المجهول سبيلا
للخروج من عنق الماساه
ركوب المجهول هذا يتمثل حينا بصعود زورق
مطاطي قد يغرق قبل ان يبحر وحين اخر في
الموت جوعا او بردا في غابه النائيه عند
اطراف القاره الاوروبيه التي تعد حلم
الهاربين من الجحيم لكن الاسوء من مراره
الخيارين الاول والثاني هو الوقوع في
براثن عصابات الاتجار بالبشر التي تجيد
استغلالك كل الظروف السابقه لايقاع عشرات
لا بل مئات الاف ضحايا في شباكها ليصبح
الانسان مجرد سلعه يتراوح سعرها بين عشره
وعشرين الف دولار حسب تقديرات الامم
المتحده
حيل وفنون عصابات التجاره بالبشر كثيره
ومتنوعه فهي تتخذ من شبكه الانترنت ومواقع
التواصل منصه الرئيسيه لايقاع ضحايا من
خلال تقديم وعود براقه بوجود فرص عمل
وتعليم في بلدان متقدمه بينما الامور على
ارض الواقع بخلاف ذلك كليا في عام 2014
اشار تقرير لمنظمه العمل الدوليه الى ان
ارباح الاتجار بالبشر على مستوى العالم
تقدر بنحو 150 مليار دولار سنويا يمثل
الاستغلال الجنسي النسبه الاكبر منها
بواقع 99 مليارات بينما يشكل الاستغلال
الاقتصادي الجبري لمجالات العمل المنزلي
والزراعه وغيرها البقيه من هذا الرقم
في حياه مو قصتي قصه ظهرت هذه السنه هذا
العام وقصه كانت سائله طوال الفتره
الماضيه الجمهور العربي قطعا حريص ان يعرف
هذا البطل البريطاني من اصول المسلم من
اصول عربيه يريد ان يعرف طبيعه القصه
نبدا بالقصه الاولى التي ظهرت او التي
كانت معك طوال حياتك ما هي القصه
ولماذا اخفيت القصه الحقيقيه
ولكنهم في كثير من الاحيان يغفلون عن
جوانب اخرى في حياتها وكما قلت مؤخرا قلت
بعمل فيلم وثائقي عن حياته لكن بشخصيه فرح
الحقيقيه وكان الامر صعبا للغايه لكن اعود
واكرر
الى قمه المجد يجب ان تجتاز العقبات التي
تعيق النجاح يجب ان تتابع احد يصل الى
القمه بسهوله ومره اخرى انا ممتا جدا لكل
الاشخاص الذين وقفوا ورائي
واؤكد مره اخرى
ما الذي يدور في ذهنك كيف اصبح هذا الرجل
شخصا ما ومره اخرى ربما لانه لم يهرب من
تلك الظروف لكن اؤكد مجددا انا ممتن جدا
لانني قادر على تحقيق ما حققته وكما قلت
انفا لقد اعددت فيلما وثائقي عن حياتي
وبكل صراحه طرح الكثير من الاسئله عن
اسباب ذكر قصه الحقيقيه ولماذا الان لماذا
لم تقل ذلك من قبل في كثير من الاحيان كان
هناك العديد من التساؤلات من هذا النوع
ساعود للقصه الاولى
انت من مواليد ارض الصومال متى غادرت كيف
كان الظروف نشاتك في تلك الفتره
او سبونج
بوب
الى المملكه المتحده عندما كنت في التاسعه
من عمري لذلك كان ذكريات المبكره عن ارض
الصومال مجرد انني كنت فردا في عائله قبل
ذلك انتقلت لجيبوتي كانت وقت الحرب
الاهليه في الصومال
في ارض الصومال الى الانفصال عن افراد
عائلتي وكما تعلم فقدت والدي في سن المبكر
في حرب الاهليه
لذلك تشققنا في اماكن مختلفه اتينا انا
واخي التوام الى جيبوتي مع عائله من
اقاربنا ومن ثم انتقلنا من جيبوتي الى
المملكه المتحده
ثمان سنوات
الى الى بريطانيا قصه كانت سائده طوال
فتره حياتك وقصه كشفت عنها في الوثائقي مع
البي بي سي هذا هذا هذا العام في 2022
لماذا احتجت ان تكون هناك قصتين لماذا لم
تكن الروايه هي الروايه الحقيقيه من المره
الاولى
نعم بصراحه كان الامر صعبا في ذلك الوقت
عندما كنت صغيرا جدا لقد تم اكتشاف من قبل
مدرس تربيه البدنيه التي دعمني في المدرسه
حين ذاك لم يكون يمكنك رؤيه سوى طفل تم
اهله ولم يتم الاعتناء به وقد لاحظت
المدرسه ذلك في وقت مبكر وعندما بلغت 13
عاما وامتلكت شجاعه الكافيه للموح بذلك
ذهبت الى المدرسه وجلس مدرسي للحديث معي
لم تكن لغه الانجليزيه جيده في ذلك الوقت
سامسونج
واخذتني الى الخدمات الاجتماعيه المحليه
حيث يعتنون بالاطفال وتم اخراجي من هذا
الوضع السيء ثم تم وضعه في منزل اخر مع
سيده اخرى نعم كان الامر صعبا في ذلك
الوقت
القصه الحقيقيه التي يعني تحدثت عنها
واظهرتها مؤخرا هناك سيده اخذتك من
الصومال في سن التاسعه وجاءت بك الى
بريطانيا
وسكنت معها في منزلها
واصبحت تعمل في خدمتها صحيح
هذه السيده لا تربط فيها اي علاقه
ليس لدي اي علاقه بتلك المراه لكن مره
اخرى واكل انه لا ينبغي لاي طفل ان يمر
بالظروف التي مررت بها لانه لا يملك
خيارات وهناك من ارغمني على هذا القرار
ولكن في الوقت نفسه يمثل للتجاره بالاطفال
جزءا كبيرا من اسباب ذلك وقد كنت واحدا
منهم وبمجرد انكشاف ذلك للمجتمع ورؤيه
اشخاص يمرون بذلك اشعر انني لست الوحيد
الذي عانى وبصراحه في كثير من الاوقات لقد
طرحت الكثير من الاسئله لماذا الان لماذا
سافعل ظللت سنوات عده امتنعوا عن الكشف عن
حياه البائسه ولكن لا يمكنك حجم تلك
المعلومات فتره طويله لدي اربعه اطفال
جميلين ما شاء الله وهم في نفس العمر الذي
كنت فيه لا استطيع ان اتخيلهم يمرون
بالظروف القاسيه التي مررت بها وهذا احد
الاسباب التي جعلتني اخرج عن صمتي واكون
صادقا مع نفسي اذ بدات في الواقع افهم
نفسي لان هناك الكثير من الاسئله تحاول
تجنب التفكير فيها لانك تعرف تبيعات
الاجابه ولذلك احتفظت بهذه التجربه
البائسه في ذاكره لسنوات والان فقط اصبحت
جاهزا نوعا ما للحصول على بعض الاجابات
وما زلت ابحث عن اجابات اخرى اربعه اعوام
عشت عشت فيها في بريطانيا من سن تسع سنوات
حتى سن 13
دوره المياه للحمام يعني وتبكي كنت تعيش
حياه قاسيه ما طبيعه الحياه التي كنت
تعيشها قبل ذهابك للمدرسه اول مره في سن
13 سنه
فيسبوك
هو بمثابه اختبار وبالنسبه ليكرر انني
ممتلئ لان الناس يهتمون لامري لو لم
يكتشفني اساتذتي في وقت مبكر في المدرسه
لكانت الحياه قاسيه
مو عشت حياه صعبه جدا من سنه تسع سنوات
حتى سنه 13 سنه السن الذي دخل فيه للمدرسه
مع اسره غريبه عنك اريد ان افهم طبيعه
المعاناه كيف كانت حياتك في السنوات
الاربعه تلك كنت تبكي كثيرا تحدثت عن هذا
الامر يعني في الفيلم الوثائقي اريد ان
يستمع الجمهور العربي لمعاناتك في تلك
السنوات الاربعه
ارسلي اسدسات
وصعبه جدا في كثير من الاحيان شعرت
بالوحده اكرر ان الامر كان صعبا وليس بيد
طفل في عمر 9 سنوات حيله لتغيير اي شيء
فيه لذا لا اتمنى ان يمر اي طفل بما مررت
به وبما عانيت منه لانه من حقي اي طفل في
الثالثه عشر من عمره ان يلعب ويمرحها
ويستمتع بوقته لا ان يعيش معاناه
صعبه
لكنني بالنظر الى الوراء اتمنى لو كان في
الامكان تغير ذلك
على ما كان عليه وافعل الاشياء التي
يمكنني التحكم فيها ساعدتني رياضه على
الهروب من واقع وكانت وسيله للخروج من
طفوله البائسه والتقدم لمستقبل هذه
السنوات الاربعه قبل المدرسه هل كنت تمارس
الرياضه الجري
ام لم تكن تمارس اي نوع من الرياضه
الرياضه
شاهدتها كانت في عام
1999 او 92
اردت ممارسه رياضه كره القدم
لاحقا عندما بلغته 16 عاما انه لن يكون
باستطاعه التميز الرياضتين كان الفضل
للمعلم في مساعده على اختيار الرياضه التي
تناسب مهارات قال لي انت تعدى يمكنك لعب
كره القدم بهدف الاستمتاع يجب ان يكون
لديك ايمان بمواهبك في هذا الميدان
والمثابره لتطوير ذاتك في سن 13 سنه دخلت
المدرسه واكتشفك المعلم واخبرته بقصتك
الحقيقيه
ونقلت الى دار رعايه اجتماعيه ثم بدا بدات
الحياه تتغير قليلا اصبحت افضل بالنسبه
ماذا يعني ان يلتحق الطفل مهاجر عاش
معاناه بالمدرسه في سن الثالثه عشر
رعايه الاجتماعيه في المملكه المتحده
ومعلم الذي دعمني لم اكن لاعلم ما اذا كنت
لاتمكن من بدا حياه جديده كان الامر صعبا
للغايه لانني لم اكن اتحدث الانجليزيه انا
ممتنا المدرسه والاشخاص الذين امنوا به في
وقت مبكر لانه لم يكن احد يعلم ماذا يحدث
ولكنهم كانوا يعلمون انني كنت جيدا في
الجري نعم الفضل الاول يعود المدرسه
عندما كان عمري 13 او 14 عاما انضمت الى
نادي
الثلاثاء والخميس كنا نجري حول الملعب
ونلعب كره القدم ونقوم برمي الرمحي والوثب
الطويل وممارسه تمارين رياضيه عده واعتقد
مجددا ان هذا ما ساعدني على الهروب من الم
وما كنت اعاني منه علاقتك مع عائلتك ما
زالت مقطوعه في تلك الفتره في سن الثالثه
عشر الرابعه عشر الخامسه عشر استمرت
مقطوعه لا يوجد تواصل
لكن لم اكن موجودا معهم ابدا ولذلك لم يكن
لدي اي اتصال وثيق بهم اشعر بالامتنان
لانني تمكنت من اكتشاف امي وعائلتي بعد
ذلك وبناء علاقه معهم وتوطيظ هذه العلاقه
اكثر بمرور السنوات
قبل ان اسمع اي شيء عنهم لقد كان الامر
مشحونا بالمشاعر وكان من الجميل رؤيه
عائلتي مره اخرى لا افكر يمكن ان يحصل
لانني لم اكن قادرا على التحكم في خيارات
المستقبليه وانا طفل صغير ولكن عندما تصبح
ناضجا يمكنك ان تمتلك خياراتك وتتخذ
قراراتك حينما بلغت المعلم في المدرسه
بقصتك الحقيقيه وبالامر وتحسن الظروف هل
شعرت بانك تحررت
من ذلك القيد من تلك الحاله التي كانت
تخسرك
اجل بالتاكيد شعرت بان حملا كبيرا ازيح عن
كاهلي وبمجرد خروج عن صمتي والكشف عن هويه
الحقيقيه شعرت انني وجدت نفسي عند اخبار
الجميع بالحقيقه وكون صادقا معهم فقد
تفهموا حالتي وحتى الان فان القيام بهذا
الفيلم الوثائقي ومشاركه قصه معهم يمثل
بالنسبه لمصدر ارتياح كبير لانني لم اعد
وحيدا ونظرا لان العديد من الاشخاص الذين
يمرون بالتجربه التي مررت بها يحتاجون
وسيله للتعبير تحفظهم امل ان اتمكن من
الهام الاشخاص غير الموجودين هنا لانهم لم
يختاروا ان يكونوا كذلك ولانهم اجبروا على
خيارات لا يرغبون فيها واكد انني ساستمر
في منح الامل في ان كل شيء ممكن
تتوقف عن الحلم ابدا اعتقد ان بمقدور اي
انسان سواء اكان كبيرا او صغيرا وان يكون
انسانا ملهما مشوارك الرياضي الرسمي كعدى
كبطل متى يعني بدا يتضح بشكل كبير ما هي
اول بطوله كبرى شاركت بها وبدات حقق
انجازات
ك التي تسكن فيها ثم لصالح منتخب انجلترا
وبعد ذلك بعد الترشح لانجلترا يقع لاختيار
عليك لتمثيل بريطانيا
لن انسى ابدا المره الاولى التي ارتديت
فيها قميص بريطانيا
هي اول بطوله تحصل فيها على الذهب بال
5000 متر والعشره الاف متر صحيح
نعم لقد كانت الالعاب الاولمبيه بالنسبه
لي الاكبر في مسيرته اذا كنت ستختار واحده
من انجازات فستكون بالتاكيد لندن كان
الجميع موحدين من حيث القوه والرياضه
والتشجيع الرياضيين وكنا كالجسد الواحد
ورياضه وضعتنا معا في ذلك الميدان رؤيه
هذه اللحمه بين الجميع عند الهتاف باسمه
رفع عن طاقته حتى انني لم اعد اسمع صوت
خطوات القدمين وانا اجري ان كان صوته
عاليا وما زال ذلك الشعور حتى اليوم
يدفعني الى الامام لمواصله تحقيق انجازات
افضل وتحسينيه
كب كيك
اعطيني لحظه قطعك للشريط هو في شريط اللي
هو شريط النهايه او خط النهايه حينما قطعت
خط النهايه في اول ذهبيه في اولمبياد ذكر
صوره خلينا نتذكرها مع بعض
ولكن
سنوات
التوتر
احلم بان اصبح بطلا اولمبيا تحقيق ذلك في
بلدك امامك اكثر من 75,000 مشجع يهتف لك
وانت تراه متاتين وتراهم يعانقون بعضهم
البعض ويحتفلون بفوزك كان امرا استثنائيا
ولا يصدق تذكر
طفل صغير تذكرت السنوات الاولى حينما جئت
الى بريطانيا حينما عشت معه اسره غريبه
واستخدمتك بشكل جائر تذكرت كل هذه البشائر
نقدر نعمل بكار الصعيد
بها ذلك الواقع المرير هو ما جعلني
الرياضي الذي انا عليه الان ربما اذا لم
اواجه كل هذه التحديات في حياتي لما كنت
تعلمت ان اكون منطبطا ومحترما لغيري وان
احسن من ادائك مرت علي لحظات لم اشعر انني
عاملت فيها بجد ولكنني ادرك انه يجب علي
بذل المزيد وان اؤمن بقدراته ماء اتذكر
وانني جئت الى المملكه المتحده وانا طفل
صغير بمفردي دون عائله ولا اتحدث كلمه
واحده بالانجليزيه
احصل على اربع ميداليات ذهبيه اولمبيه
فارس من ملكه بريطانيا ابذل قصار جهدي
لمزيد من الانجازات لا يمكن تخيل ذلك
انسان اعلم ان كل شيء ممكن الحصوله في
الحياه اليوم قد يكون في القمه وغدا قد
اكون في القاع ولكن في نهايه الامر كلنا
بشر
اولمبياد لندن 2012 حققت الذهب لدينا هنا
كثير من الذهب في ريو دي جانيرو ايضا حققت
الذهب في الاولمبياد الثاني همم كيف كان
ينظر لك الشعب
البريطاني بشكل عام الدوله الاجهزه
المؤسسات الرياضيه الاعلام الانجليزي
والبريطاني كيف كان ينظر للمو فرح وهو
يحقق له انجاز الكتل الاخر
سنحصل على بعضها
اولمبيه وبالنسبه لو لم احظى بدعم من
الاشخاص الذين شجعوني ومشاهده الاطفال
الصغار فلم اكون لاحقق ذلك لذا اعود واكرر
اشعر بالامتنان الشديد للاشخاص الذين
كانوا في حياته لانه ليس من السهل الفوز
بمداليتين اولمبيتين ثم العوده بعد اربع
سنوات للفوز بمداليات ذهبيه اخرى انه
انجاز صعب عندما تكون رياضيا في هذا
المستوى سيتوجب عليك الاستمرار
والتغلب على الرياضيات
ايضا بريطاني ماذا يعني ان تكون او تحوز
على هذا اللقب
فنقول السير مو فرح
ان مانشستر
يونانيه للاسف هذا العام بصراحه انا لا
اعرف كيف اعبر عن ذلك جئت الى المملكه
المتحده طفلا صغيرا لم اكن اتحدث من اللغه
الانجليزيه الا بضع كلمات وحقا كنت طفلا
منعزلا ثقافيا ولم اكن اعرف اي شيء في هذا
البلد انها دوله جديده ثم تصبح انت هذه
الدوله لقد ارسلتني بريطانيا
البدنيه الخاصه ونظام رعايه الاجتماعيه لم
استطعت تحقيق انجازات
ثمار كفاح ثم ان يتم اختيارك من قبل
الجمهور ومن قبل الدوله ليتم تتويجه وان
تحصل على لقب فارس من قبل صاحبه الجلاله
كان امرا لا يصدق اعتقد انها واحده من
اكثر اللحظات التي تبعث على الفخر في
حياته وكما
انا من اشد المعجبين بكره القدم كان السر
اليكس فيريكسون شخصا مهما مدرب رائع
لمانشستر يونايتد وقد حصل على لقبي فارس
ومن ثم ان اكون مثل واحصل على لقب فارس
كان امرا لا يصدق هنا في بريطانيا كيف
يصنع البطل العداء كيف يتم صناعه وتاهيل
ليكون بطلا عالميا
لكن اكرر العمل الشاق وتعلم
النظاميات
مثل نور الدين المرسلين وهشام
الكروجين ولكننا فقدنا بعضهم في المملكه
المتحده ولذلك اعتقد انه يتوجب علينا
اعاده النظر في البرامج الرياضيه المدرسيه
عندما
شخص ما ويشد بما حققته من انجازات يشعر
الاخرون انهم مهما بذلوا من جهد فلن
يستطيعوا تحقيق ما حققته لانهم ببساطه لا
يذللون العقبات ويعتقدون لانني توجتك بطل
وظهرت على التلفاز فانهم لن يستطيعوا
الوصول الى القمه وتحقيق انجازات ولكن يجب
ان يعلم الجميع انني سمعت ذلك بنفسي وحققت
تلك الانجازات لاتوج بطلا على شاشات
التلفاز لذلك علينا ان نغرس في جيل الشباب
ان ثمن النجاح هو العمل الجاد والتاني نحن
جميعا سنواجهه عقبات في حياتنا سواء كنا
رياضيين ام لا الامر بما ثابت تعليم الناس
ما يمكنه من القيام به وما يمكن تحقيقه من
المفيد لتعليم اطفال
انجازاتهم وبطولاتهم سؤال الرياضيه او
الاقتصاديه او السياسيه او حتى العلميه في
الدول المتقدمه
ماذا لو لم ياتي مو فرح الى بريطانيا ماذا
لو بقي في الصومال
تتخيل هذه الصوره تاتيك احيانا
اذا لم اغادر ارض الصومال مطلقا لم اكن
لاحقق ما حققته واكون الرياضيه والبطله
الذي تتحدث اليه الان لانه كما قلت تما
منحي فرصه لتغيير حياتي وقد حققت نجاحا في
معظمها وبكل صدق انا فخور بتمثيل بلدي
وفخور لكون بريطانيا لانه اذا لم احصل على
دعم نظام الرعايه البريطاني لما اكون
لاحقق اشياء عظيمه كيف تنظر لمن بقيه هناك
في بلداننا سواء العربيه او الافريقيه ما
يسمى دول العالم الثالث الاشخاص الذين
تقتل مواهبهم لا ترتاح لهم فرص لتحقيق
انجازات
انا شاكر لما حققتها
للاشخاص الذين قدموا لي الدعم لكن واكد
انه لا ينبغي ابدا ان ننسى الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون في سيناري مختلف الامر متروك لنا
لمواصله دعمهم وتثقيفهم ورد الجميل وهذا
امر كبير هذا ما اريد القيام به من خلال
الرياضه مع الناس في افريقيا والصومال او
حتى الذين يعيشون في الدول العربيه المهم
دائما ان نفكر في الاخرين ايضا لانه كما
تعلم انا حافظت كثيرا من الانجازات واتمنى
لغير ذلك ايضا لاننا جميعا متساهون يحدث
امرين
متناقضي من ناحيه هذه الدول فيها حاله
عنصريه فيها اضطهاد احيانا للمهاجرين من
اصول سواء مسلمه هنديه افريقيه ومن ناحيه
اخرى
الحقيقه انه ما يتعرض له المهاجرون بشكل
عام في الدول المتقدمه هو احتوائهم
واستيعابهم وتمكينهم من من اظهار قدراته
انت في اي زاويه في اي اتجاه تنظر للمساله
هل تشعر انه هذه الدول المتقدمه مذنبه
باتجاه المهاجرين ام تشعر بانها على
النقيض من ذلك هي من قدم لهم فرصه ان
يكونوا مميزين وبازين
مختلفه بالنسبه لي انا فخور بكوني
بريطانيا
لذلك علينا دائما ان نشجع الاشخاص الذين
يعيشون خارج بريطانيا ونعلمه ان كل شيء
يصبح ممكن مع الاراده والتصميم لا احد
يستطيع اختيار ان يكون في مكانه معينه
انها اقدر الحياه وايضا علينا ان ننظر الى
الامور من ناحيه الانسانيه ونواصل دعم
الاخرين واحياء الامل في نفوسهم في هويه
فرح في ما يتعلق بهويه فرح تشعر بان بانك
مسلم وان هذا هذا الامر يعني مهم جدا في
حياتك تشعر باصولك العربيه الصوماليه اما
ان هذا الامر ابتعدى مركز على جانب
البريطاني في هويتك بالانجليزي
براون بالنسبه لي انا فخور بكوني مسلم
وانا فخور لتحقيق اشياء عظيمه فهذا جزء
كبير مما افعله هذا ما يجعلني الرجل الذي
انا عليه وان تكون ممتنا والا تتبجح بنفسك
لاننا كلنا بشر واعتقد انه اذا لم يكن لدي
ايمان ودين فلن اكون قادرا على الفهم
واحترام الاخرين والاستمرار قدوما
بالطريقه التي انا عليها الان ومعامله
الناس بطريقه التي تريد ان تعامل بها
كعداد بريطاني مسلم اليوم كاس العالم اكبر
بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم اكبر بطوله
عالميه تقام في بلد عربي ومسلم هو وقطر
وبلد صغير
هل انت سعيد
الامر يتعلق بالاتصال روابطه بين الناس
اعتقد اننا كثيرا ما نطرح اسئله مثل لماذا
يشكل اختلاف الوان البشره
يمنعنا من التقارب على العكس يجب ان نبنيه
بحيث لا يهم معرفه اصولك وديانتك كل الناس
سواسيه
لا اريد ان ادخلك في السياسه ولكن قدرت
تعرض لهجمه اوروبيه من كثير من الدول
المانيا وغيرها وهجمات منظمه دائمه انه
كانه في استكثار ان بلد عربي مسلم صغير
يقوم باستضافه بطوله كاس العالم كيف تنظر
لهذه الحملات الموجهه ضد استضافه قطر لكاس
العالم
اللعبه تحظى باكبر عدد من المشجعين اعتقد
وان بطوله كاس العالم في قطر ستكون نسخه
مميزه ورائعه لكن في كل ما نقوم به يجب ان
نعلم انه لن يشعر الجميع بالسعاده من اجلك
عليك تقبل تلك الحقيقه ولكن يجب ان يظهر
للجميع كيف يمكن استخدام القوه والرياضه
لاحداث فرق في حياه الاخرين وطالما انني
اقوم بالعمل على الوجه الصحيح واذلل
العقبات التي تواجهني في مسيره المهنيه
انني على يقين ان الوصول الى القمه ليس
سهلا ابدا
ستكون هناك في الدوحه
الى الذهاب الى كاس العالم
ثم بعد ذلك ان شاء الله عندما اعود سا
وابني الى مباراه كره القدم ونحن كاع
عائله من اكبر المشجعين للعبه
لدينا بطاقه موسميه لنادي ارسنال غالبا ما
نذهب الى المباراه كره القدم تحظى بمكانه
كبيره في منزلنا وشكرا جزيلا لك شكرا سعيد
جدا وكما ذكرت مشاهدينا الكرام في بدايه
في مقدمه الحلقه كنا في حضره الذهب هذا
الذهب الذي يلمع والذي تقف خلفه تجربه
صعبه وفرح ولكنه استطاع ان يتجاوزها وهذه
تجربه ملهمه لكثير من الشباب حقيقه الشباب
العربي وغير العربي اشكر لكم الطيب
المتابعه القاكم في الاسبوع المقبل بخير
وفي امان الله
نسوان